♪♪
[ TIRES SCREECH ]
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE DOMINO
EFFECT, WHERE A SINGLE EVENT
CAUSES A CHAIN REACTION
OF SIMILAR EVENTS.
THE MOST FAMOUS EXAMPLE BEING,
OF COURSE, DOMINOES,
BUT WHAT IF A DOMINO COULD TIP
OVER MORE THAN ITS OWN WEIGHT,
AND WHAT IF EACH SUBSEQUENT
DOMINO GOT BIGGER AND HEAVIER?
COULD YOU GET
TO EPIC PROPORTIONS
WITH THAT DOMINO EFFECT?
THAT IS OUR QUESTION.
CAN PUSHING OVER A SINGLE HUMBLE
DOMINO SET OFF A CHAIN REACTION
OF BIGGER AND BIGGER DOMINOES
UNTIL YOU COULD CRUSH A CAR?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY AND ANSWER,
AND I HAVE FAITH IN THIS GUY.
I HAVE NAMED HIM "DOMINIC."
Jesse: WEIGHING IN AT A WHOPPING
7,016 POUNDS
AT A HEIGHT OF 14.42 FEET
IS DOMINO NUMBER 12!
I DON'T REALLY FEEL LIKE ONE
OF THOSE ANNOUNCERS SO MUCH
AS A KID RUNNING OUT OF BREATH
SCREAMING FOR HIS DEAR LIFE.
Narrator: NEXT UP AT
2,081 POUNDS IS NUMBER 11.
IT SOUNDS LIKE
A LARGE DRUM.
DOMINO NUMBER 11 IS GOING UP.
Narrator:
TO MAKE WEIGHT, HE'S ON
A PREFIGHT DIET OF CONCRETE.
Adam: WELL, ALL OF OUR
HEAVY STEEL DOMINOES,
THE LATTER HALF OF THE SEQUENCE,
ARE IN PLACE.
IT ONLY TOOK
A COUPLE OF FORKLIFTS,
ABOUT 12 PEOPLE,
AND TWICE AS MUCH TIME
AS WE WERE HOPING
TO SPEND ON IT.
LUCKY NUMBER 11.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR TEAM DOMINO
TO COME OUT
AND SET UP THE FRONT HALF
OF THE RIG.
REMEMBER, THEY HAD GREAT RESULTS
WITH THIS IN THE SHOP,
BUT THE ENTIRE SEQUENCE
HAS NEVER BEEN TESTED.
IT IS STILL JUST
A THEORETICAL EXERCISE
UNTIL CANNAN TIPS OVER DOMINIC.
THAT'S WHEN WE FIND OUT
IF THIS WORKS.
Narrator:
WITH THE FINAL PREP IN PROGRESS,
CUE THE UNFORTUNATE CRUSHEE.
CHECK OUT OUR NEW CAR.
HER NAME IS CARLATA PARK-A-LOT.
I'M DEFINITELY LOOKING FORWARD
TO CRUSHING MY FIRST CAR
SINCE I HAVEN'T EVEN
DRIVEN ONE YET.
ALL RIGHT.
LOOKS GOOD.
LET'S CRUSH THE CAR.
Narrator:
FIRST UP, ADAM CLUES IN CANNAN
ON A KEY MYTH-BUSTING SKILL --
SHOUTING.
Adam: I NEED YOU TO CALL IT OUT,
AND IT'S LIKE THIS --
THIS IS DOMINO CAR CRUSHER
IN THREE, TWO, ONE,
AND THEN BOINK.
OKAY.
CAN YOU GIVE ME --
LET ME HEAR IT.
LET ME HEAR THE VOICE.
THIS IS DOMINO CAR CRUSHER
IN THREE, TWO, ONE, BOINK.
BEAUTIFUL.
Narrator:
WITH THE COUNTDOWN REHEARSAL
DOWN PAT, THE SETUP IS COMPLETE.
EVERY SINGLE CONTACT
HAS TO BE PERFECT.
NEXT ONE, STRAIGHTEN IT UP,
THERE WE GO.
Narrator:
THE SPACING AND ALIGNMENT
IS DOUBLE...
OKAY.
SO, OH...
WELL, WE KNOW THAT FIVE, SIX,
AND SEVEN ARE WORKING GREAT.
-DEFINITELY.
-...AND THEN TRIPLE CHECKED.
THIS IS A 1-IN-100 SHOT,
AND THEY HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT
FIRST TIME.
-EXCELLENT.
AWESOME.
I WAS REALLY NERVOUS
THAT EIGHT AND NINE
AND MAYBE EVEN 10
WOULD FALL OVER.
IF THEY HAD FALLEN
BEFORE WE WERE READY,
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY BAD.
-OKAY.
-OH.
WE'RE IN THE ZONE.
WE'RE READY TO DO THIS.
-ALL RIGHT.
-ALL SAFETIES ARE OFF.
♪♪
I'M PUTTING YOUR
HEARING PROTECTION ON.
ALL RIGHT?
-THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
♪♪
YOU READY?
-READY.
CALL IT IN, SIR.
CAR-CRUSH TEST BY DOMINO
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
♪♪
Adam: COME ON!
OH!
-NO!
DON'T ANYBODY MOVE.
I FOUND A TOOL.
♪♪
OH, MY GOSH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, MY GOD.
THAT IS CRAZY.
YEAH!
OH, MY GOD.
-THAT IS JOY.
-WE JUST DID THAT.
Adam: OH, MY GOD.
YOU GUYS, THAT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
I CANNOT BELIEVE...
-OH, MY GOD.
...HOW WELL THAT WORKED...
COME ON.
...UP UNTIL THAT RECALCITRANT
LAST DOMINO,
BUT YOU CRUSHED A CAR.
Narrator:
CONSIDERING THE SENSITIVITY
OF THE CHAIN REACTION
AND DESPITE THE FINAL DOMINO
REQUIRING A HINT OF PERSUASION,
IN ESSENCE, IT WORKED.
WITH NO CHANCE TO RESET
AND TRY AGAIN,
THE TEAM WILL HAVE TO CALL IT
BASED ON THIS TEST ALONE.
THIS FEELING,
THE CALM AFTER THE STORM,
IT'S AN OLD FAMILIAR
FEELING FOR ME,
AND IT'S PARTICULARLY DELIGHTFUL
TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE IT
FOR A NEW GENERATION.
DUDES.
LOOK AT WHAT
YOU HAVE WROUGHT.
I'D SAY THE LAST DOMINO
HAS A BIG CRUSH ON THIS CAR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I GOT A PITY LAUGH
FROM CANNAN.
Jesse: SO HOW DO YOU GUYS WANT
TO CALL THIS MYTH?
Adam: OKAY.
YOU GUYS REMOVED SO MANY TINY,
TINY VARIABLES FROM EVERY SINGLE
SETUP TO GET IT RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO SAY IT'S PLAUSIBLE.
-PLAUSIBLE IT IS.
-ALL RIGHT.
WELL-DONE, MYTHBUSTERS!
♪♪